yeah
[Music]
so PlayStation Plus changed and now
those of us with PS plus extra and
premium have a second bunch of games to
look forward to each month unlike the
essential games we receive the extra
games rotate in and out of the
collection so in future I'll be sure to
let you know which ones are leaving the
catalog too so let's do this July 2022
the first ever extra update the headline
Act is stray coming on July 19th we play
as a cat lost in a mysterious forgotten
City filled with humanoid machines we
are trying to get back to our family and
must solve puzzles along the way as
we're a cat we can fit into places a
human cannot but simple tasks that you
and I take for granted take a little bit
more effort when you're a cat on top of
puzzle solving there is a focus on
platforming and escaping these Critters
we'll be given new skills along the way
such as this light beam which
annihilates those pesky bugs stray is
brand spanking new and is yours on July
19th oh and uh Legend has it we'll need
need to meow 100 times for a trophy next
we have Final Fantasy VII remake
integrate this includes the yuffie DLC
known as intermission remake tells the
story of the original 1997 game but it's
now clear the direction changes and a
new adventure unfolds for example yuffie
has a side story telling us how this
ninja became one of the main casts
stealing midgar's Materia if none of
that made any sense at all to you then
rest assured the gameplay is good enough
to keep you playing a blend of real-time
combat which builds up an ATB meter
which then lets us unleash real attacks
one of the most impressive elements is
the switching seamlessly between other
characters in the group and chaining
your attacks together reviewers promise
us both the story and gameplay are
magnificent with an average score of 9
out of 10. did you know the new Saints
Row game releases next month a soft
reboot of the series to wet our
appetites Saints Row 4 re-elected has
been added to the extra catalog Saints
Row was one's a rival to GTA yet over
the years it became so over the top it
was more of a caricature of its
inspiration Saints Row 4 re-elected is
the 2015 version of the game with all
DLC included like a story of how the
Saints Saved Christmas and there's one
about literally going to hell to save
the president of the United States yeah
it's really weird we'll be collecting
superpowers which let us jump for miles
and even spread wings and fly and we'll
have so many weapons to choose from like
a minigun attached to a chair if you're
up for some silly dumb fun Saints Row 4
could be worth your time reviewers tell
us it's an 8 out of 10 game but that was
all the way back in 2013. next Ubisoft
games the partnership between Sony and
Ubisoft means we'll regularly receive
games you'll know of and to begin with
there's not one there's not two there's
five Assassin's Creed games Black Flag
Unity Rogue Freedom Cry and the Ezio
collection which is actually another
three games Assassin's Creed 2
Brotherhood and revelation and that
includes two short films as well so nine
Assassin's Creed experiences for you to
choose from the gameplay was more about
staying out of sight in these older
games and using your hidden blade
sparingly unlike the modern games but if
you want to go in head first it's still
an option Black Flag is the most unique
of all these games as it sets during the
Golden Age of piracy the story in black
flag has us reliving some great pirate
moments from history and you can even
become your own version of Jack Sparrow
as you explore the Caribbean some of
these titles are very old now the first
time we saw Ezio was 2009 and a lot of
gaming standards have changed in those
13 years so keep that in mind if you
choose to relive Assassin's Creed
history but wait there's more Marvel's
Avengers drops on both PS4 and PS5 an
action-adventure game that received a
great deal of negative press due to how
lackluster the end game content was but
let's try and turn this frown upside
down the campaign the story doesn't get
enough love if you're a fan of the
Avengers I do recommend playing through
it Miss Marvel is the glue that keeps
the story pushing forward as The
Avengers all reunite and also there's
been a ton of updates since its release
including Spider-Man and now in
multiplayer mode you can all pick the
same character so lots of Spider-Mans as
it's the first month of PS plus extra we
get the biggest game you can imagine Paw
Patrol on a roll okay I'm sure you've
noticed we're entering into games I know
nothing about so if any of the following
games are worth our time please let us
know in the comments below maybe you'd
like to play Jumanji the video game you
could be the rock or Jack Black what
more could you want how about Ice Age
scratch nutty Adventure already set
Heroes on PS4 or maybe spirits of the
north a game in the same vein as Journey
without any direction or dialogue and
some would say without any narrative at
all okay so that's all 15 games and DLCs
added to extra this month arriving on
July 19th let me know your thoughts and
if you'd like this series to continue
I'm Adam you're awesome I'll see you
next time